our Kendall Jenner and NBA star Blake  Griffin dating oh my god just be cool  Kendall was spotted making a quick dash  to the exit at Avenue nightclub in LA  Tuesday night and not too far behind the  21 year old model was Griffin also  heading out of the Travis Scott concert  after-party trying to keep a low profile  Kendall covered her face as she made her  getaway to the car she rocked a figure  fitting black mini dress paired with an  oversized white t-shirt and knee-high  boots and eye witness says the pair left  in the same limo around 1:00 a.m. I like  to keep my private life pretty private  so I try my best but at the same time I  don't I don't like to let being seen out  in public with someone like affect my  everyday life  kendall has recently been tied to ASAP  rocky but this latest sighting has  sparked new romance rumors putting her  relationship with the 28 year old rapper  in question doing me like trying to be  the best I can be  [Music]  you